die sitzungen am freitag konnte zwischen
den fraktionen keine tagesordnung
vereinbart werden
die fraktion der afg hat dem vorschlag
der anderen fraktionen widersprochen den
bundestag mit der vorgeschlagenen
tagesordnung einberufen und nach § 21
absatz 3 unserer geschäftsordnung ist
für die genehmigung der tagesordnung ein
beschluss den aber ist es erforderlich
es ist in der fraktion l vereinbart
worden die noch zu beschließenden
tagesordnung um die in der zusatzpunkt
die liste aufgeführten punkte zu
erweitern von der frist für den beginn
der beratungen soll soweit erforderlich
abgewichen werden
am donnerstag soll der
tagesordnungspunkt 37 buchstaben j mit
einer 30-minütigen aussprache nach
tagesordnungspunkte 26 aufgerufen werden
der tagesordnungspunkt 37 v wo gott
hoffentlich reicht s alphabete ja vielen
dank und in der tat zum auftakt dieser
sitzungswoche ist die
bundesbildungsministerin angekündigt
hier sehen sie sie schon macht sich
schon bereit das ganze ist ja hier ja
auf eine gute stunde angesetzt ist anja
karliczek kann ein einleitendes
statements machen es könnte natürlich
könnte man vermuten unter anderem um die
lage der studierenden in der kroner
pandemie gehen denn das sommersemester
hat ja in diesen tagen gerade angefangen
und viele studierende leiden ja unter
der korona pandemie kein
präsenzunterricht ihre nebenjobs etwa
beispielsweise in der gastronomie haben
viele verloren also das könnte ein thema
sein
die fragen der abgeordneten die sind
vorher nicht bekannt die fraktionen
fragen dann reihum zu einem beliebigen
thema aus diesem ressort und wir wollen
nur daran erinnern
die bundesbildungsministerin ist ja auch
noch bundesministerin für forschung und
dann natürlich im blickfeld
beispielsweise wenn es um die
impfstoffforschung geht oder auch um die
erforschung eines medikamentes gegen
kuwait 19 also das alles gleich in
wenigen minuten aber zum auftakt dieser
sitzungswoche hat der
bundestagspräsident wolfgang schäuble
immer noch einige formalien abzuhandeln
da geht es beispielsweise darum dass
abgestimmt werden muss über die
tagesordnung ob das ganze an den
nächsten drei tagen
in der reihenfolge stattfinden kann oder
auch nicht und am freitag übrigens da
steht ja jetzt dass bevölkerungsschutz
gesetz auf der tagesordnung das am
meisten sozusagen in rede stand jetzt
aber erstmal die befragen der
bundesregierung wie angekündigt mit anja
karliczek präsident liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen bildung und forschung
genießen hier im parlament aber auch in
der bundesregierung höchste priorität
und deswegen haben wir in dieser
legislaturperiode auf der einen seite
strukturelle veränderungen initiiert und
gleichzeitig so viel wie noch nie in
bildung und forschung investiert mit
mittlerweile 20 8 milliarden euro
fördern wir maßnahmen und programme zur
stärkung der wettbewerbsfähigkeit und
der zukunftsfähigkeit unseres
innovations- landes deutschland lassen
sie mich einige beispiele herausgreifen
der erste in europa zugelassene gegen
des corona virus wirksamer impfstoff ist
in von biontech in mainz entwickelt
worden
ein unternehmen das das bmwf schon in
der gründungsphase gefördert hat und
dass kein anderes land außer den usa in
diesem bereich so viel investiert zeigt
wie viel wert wir auf die zukunft legen
und auf die entwicklung auch eines
eigenen corona impfstoffes gelegt haben
beim grünen wasserstoff haben wir das
potenzial auch früh erkannt und treiben
mit unserer förderung die
technologieentwicklung voran
damit deutschland ausrüster der welt für
grünen wasserstoff werden kann und im
konjunkturpaket haben wir deshalb auch
einen ganz klaren schwerpunkt auf
zukunftstechnologien gesetzt wie zum
beispiel künstliche intelligenz quanten
und kommunikationstechnologien aber eben
auch die batterieforschung wir haben die
attraktivität von ausbildung und studium
gestärkt hin zu mehr vergleichbarkeit
und verzahnung und einem ganz starken
fokus auch auf das lebenslange lernen
wir erleben dass sich die strukturen von
akademischer und beruflicher ausbildung
in der transformation gesellschaft
stetig weiterentwickeln
und das gilt es dann natürlich auch in
der bildungsfinanzierung immer wieder
nachzujustieren
wir haben in dieser legislaturperiode
die wissenschafts pakete verstetigt
dafür investieren bund und länder über
die nächsten zehn jahre 160 milliarden
euro
und so viel freiheit und so viel
sicherheit für auf der einen seite
außeruniversitäre forschung auf der
anderen seite für die hochschulen hat es
noch nie gegeben
die hochschulen sind natürlich genauso
von der schließung betroffen wie die
schulen allerdings ist die
digitalisierung der lehre in den
hochschulen viel weiter fortgeschritten
als in den schulen und deswegen lief
auch von beginn an in den hochschulen in
der digitalen wäre einiges besser als in
den schulen aber auch das war der grund
warum wir schon vor der krise die
digitalisierung der schulen mit dem
digital parkschule vorangetrieben haben
mittlerweile nachdem er jetzt in der
krise noch einmal 1,5 milliarden euro
draufgelegt haben stellen wir den
ländern 65 milliarden euro dafür zur
verfügung die digitalisierung in den
schulen voranzutreiben und das sich bei
der digitalisierung der schulen aber
auch in den hochschulen noch weiterhin
spürbar etwas tut geht ganz vor allem
auf die packte und die unterstützung
zurück aus unserem haus auch wenn ich
mir gerade auch beim digital packt
schule ein höheres tempo beim ausgeben
der mittel natürlich wünschen würde
um schülerinnen und schülern zu helfen
ihre pandemie bedingten lern rückstände
aufzuholen erarbeiten wir aktuell mit
den ländern ein gemeinsames nachhilfe
programm
und deswegen ist es auch wichtig dass
die länder jetzt lernen stände erheben
weil sie nur dann gezielt nach steuern
können
bei den schulen unterstützen wir die
länder bis an die grenzen des rechtlich
möglichen um aber die großen
herausforderungen insbesondere der
digitalen bildung meistern zu können
brauchen wir für die zukunft neue engere
formen der zusammenarbeit von bund und
ländern und zwar auf klar erweiterter
rechtsgrundlage
ein zweiter punkt wir müssen wesentlich
souveräner werden und zwar technologisch
in europa gilt es jetzt technologisch
souveräner und unabhängiger zu werden
und wir müssen in der lage sein
schlüsseltechnologien zu verstehen sie
selbst herzustellen und sie am ende auch
weiterzuentwickeln
weil wir nur so diese ganzen
technologischen entwicklungen im sinne
unserer werte mitgestalten können und
genau deshalb werden wir auch in zukunft
in kw quantentechnologie
kommunikationssysteme mikroelektronik
und weitere schlüssel technologien
investieren in der pandemie haben wir
gesehen wie groß die internationalen
abhängigkeiten auch in wichtigen
bereichen der öffentlichen
daseinsvorsorge sind und deswegen ist es
ein ziel aus unserem haus deutschland
wieder zur apotheke der welt zu machen
dafür brauchen wir exzellente
forschungskapazitäten und exzellente
agile produktions entwicklungen in
europa auch jenseits aktueller
notwendigkeiten und liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen in dieser legislaturperiode
sind viele grundlagen für unsere
technologische entwicklung und auch für
die modernisierung der bildung gelegt
worden
diesen kurs wollen und werden wir
fortsetzen mutig technologieoffen und
mit einem ganz klaren blick auf die
herausforderungen der zukunft
herzlichen dank und jetzt beantworte ich
gern ihre fragen
die erste frage stellen der kollege
george glueck fremming afd
vielen dank herr präsident
frau ministerin ihr bricht kein bisschen
wie aus einer anderen besseren zeit wie
sie wissen ist ja die lage an unseren
bildungseinrichtungen zunehmend nicht
nur an den schulen sondern auch an den
hochschulen dramatisch seit einem jahr
handeln wir uns von lockdown zu lockdown
die familien sind stark belastet wir
hören von den krisenzentren in berlin
dass die anzahl der jungen menschen die
über suizid nachdenken steigt meine
frage ist was tun sie was tut der bund
denn die schulschließungen trägt der
bund ja mit er treibt sie mit voran was
tun sie konkret um unseren schülern
unserer jugend zu helfen aus dieser lage
herauszukommen werden heute im ausschuss
gehört dass gespräche jetzt ein jahr
nach beginn der pandemie offenbar
begonnen worden sind zwischen ihnen oder
bund und ländern dazu frage ich konkret
was ist ihr konzept für die zeit bis zu
den sommerferien damit dieses schuljahr
kein verlorenes schuljahr wird wie viele
schulen wurden bereits bundesweit mit
luftfiltern ausgestattet wie hilft hier
der bund
was ist ihr plan um den bei den schülern
entstandenen lärm rückstand wieder
aufzuholen es reicht wenn ich ihnen nur
festzustellen wir müssen jetzt schon
damit beginnen ihn aufzuholen und
schließlich auch an den hochschulen
haben wir ein problem die studierenden
gehen jetzt das vierte online semester
was tun sie damit auch an den
hochschulen der lern rückstand aufgeholt
werden kann
vielen dank herzlichen dank für die
frage das war jetzt viel denn in einer
minute das zu beantworten ist glaube ich
nicht so einfach aber in den schulen
geht es jetzt erst einmal darum auf
jeden fall ein sicheres arbeitsumfeld zu
schaffen also konzepte zu entwickeln die
sicheres lernen und lehren möglich
machen in verbindung mit testen aber
natürlich auch wir haben die
priorisierung gerade der lehrkräfte im
grundschulbereich oder auch der erzieher
im kita-bereich hoch gesetzt weil da das
abstandhalten nicht so einfach ist und
deswegen wollen wir da dass die lernen
dass die lehrkräfte er geimpft werden
auch das trägt natürlich zur sicherheit
in den schulen bei das thema luft fehlt
heißt angesprochen wurde
und es gibt sogenannte es drei
richtlinien die einen standard des
sicheren arbeitsumfeldes ermöglichen die
einen standard von therapien im
medizinischen bereich ermöglichen und
diese erst drei richtlinien sind ein
konzept was man dann in den schulen
umsetzen kann wo man sich die einzelnen
aspekte von der mobilität also von dem
verkehr der schüler hin in die schule
bis hin zu wechsel unterricht oder eben
auch den lüftungs filtern nur ein
gesamtes konzept kann eine echte lösung
geben und zu dem thema nachhilfe
vielleicht so viel ich habe es gerade
erwähnt wir sind dabei mit den ländern
ein konzept zu erarbeiten wir wollen
aber ganz bewusst erst in das neue
schuljahr damit gehen wir wollen in den
sommerferien und auch in der zeit danach
und da dann ja hoffentlich besseren und
sichereren und einfacheren bedingungen
dann das thema nachhilfe aufrufen wir
merken ja alle das ist im moment sehr
sehr anstrengend ist und sie haben es
gerade selber angesprochen die müdigkeit
der familien die müdigkeit schülerinnen
und schülern oder eben auch unseren
hochschülern ist da die ist nicht
wegzudiskutieren deswegen sollten wir
ihnen jetzt nicht noch zusätzliche
aufgaben geben sondern ab dem herbst das
nachholprogramm starten und vielleicht
über die sommerferien das thema
persönlichkeitsentwicklung und eben auch
den diese teamarbeit wieder zu stärken
schon mal damit beginnen da wie mal
darauf hinweisen dass wir eigentlich
frage und antwort jeweils auf eine
minute begrenzen wollen und es wird auch
durch die ampel angezeigt und durch das
gelb leuchtendes schon vorher
rechtzeitig gewarnt sie wollen eine
nachfrage stellen der kollege dank herr
präsident ist dafür auch ganz kurz vor
ministern
sie sprachen dass nachhilfe programm an
der bund hat hier ja einen einstelligen
milliardenbetrag glaube ich zugesagt
eine milliarde
die lehrerverbände fordern das doppelte
andere länder um deutschland herum haben
wesentlich mehr hierfür zur verfügung
gestellt können sie sich vorstellen hier
noch etwas draufzulegen
die milliarde ist daraus entstanden dass
man erst mal geguckt hat was ist
überhaupt eine größenordnung die man
braucht wir gehen davon aus dass 20 bis
25 prozent der schülerinnen und schüler
betroffen sind und unterstützung
brauchen das wird aber unterstützung in
unterschiedlicher form sein
die aufgabe die nachhilfe langfristig zu
organisieren
und auch in gänze zu organisieren ist
eine aufgabe der länder den schulen sind
aufgabe der länder
wir wollen die länder unterstützen wir
wollen diesen anschub geben wir wollen
die lernstandserhebung auch weil damit
ganz gezielt geholfen werden kann aber
ich glaube es ist richtig wenn mir dann
die verantwortung wieder in die hände
der länder legen oliver kaczmarek ist
bitte stellt die nächste frage vielen
dank herr präsident frau ministerin ich
möchte noch mal nachfragen zu den
maßnahmen die sie mit den ländern
diskutieren zum aufholen von lern
rückständen das ist ja richtig wir
wissen dass die schulen oder den
schülerinnen und schüler mit lern
rückstände in die schule zurück kommen
aber ich frage mich ob es das wichtigste
ist jetzt nach hilfe zu organisieren
ich bin mir sicher dass es nicht das
einzige ist was man tun muss deshalb die
frage wie gehen sie mit den meldungen um
das wir bei soziale folgen der korona
pandemie über psychosoziale belastungen
und auch viele meldungen erhalten und
ist da eine erweiterung denkbar aus
ihrer sicht also wir haben schon
frühzeitig auch schon im letzten sommer
über das mit dem kult programm kultur
macht stark ganz gezielt programme
angeboten aus unserem haus die dann
gemischt worden sind durch programme in
den ländern um einen sogenannten lern
sommer zu ermöglichen ich habe ganz
gezielt zusammen mit der kollegin karin
prien in schleswig holstein ein lern
sommer schleswig holstein auf den weg
gebracht wo es ganz klar darum ging
sowohl die persönlichkeitsentwicklung
sowohl die sozialen und emotionalen
aspekte in den mittelpunkt zu stellen
und nicht nur das lernen natürlich muss
es eine kombination sein denn gerade
jugendliche im heranwachsenden alter
entwickeln sich natürlich und auch da
ist bestimmt was auf der strecke
geblieben nachfrage gerade der resident
sie haben gerade auch nochmal erwähnt
dass für diese form der zusammenarbeit
von bund und ländern andere rechtliche
grundlagen geschaffen werden müssen das
ist eine neue form der kooperation geben
müsste können sie uns sagen kann was sie
da genau denken und warum wir das nicht
jetzt in dieser wahlperiode einfach nur
miteinander besprechen ich würde glaube
ich hier im haus einen breiten mehrheit
für eine erweiterung der kooperation von
bund und ländern sehen ja aber eine
grundgesetzänderung hat besondere
vorschriften und hat auch besondere
zeiten die man einkalkulieren muss um
sie von anfang bis ende durchsetzen zu
können
es geht uns darum im bereich der
digitalen bilder
klein aber fein eine
gemeinschaftsaufgabe zu definieren
ich habe gestern zum beispiel mit dem
innovationsland deutschland ein sehr
interessantes gespräch gehabt mit einem
physiker der sich im bereich der der
techno lud der der der der
lichttechnologien bewegt und er hat ein
ganz tolles video gezeigt dieses video
inhaltlich in den physikunterricht
einspeisen zu können als option diese
möglichkeit haben wir heute nicht weil
es darum inhalte geht und weil wir so
etwas nicht einmal zur verfügung stellen
dürfen da müssen wir jetzt erst
langjährige verträge mit den ländern
machen und genau an dieser stelle wäre
es glaube ich sinnvoll wenn wir richtung
berufsorientierung eigene möglichkeiten
hätten eben auch inhaltlich etwas zur
verfügung zu stellen
dr jens brandenburg fdp steht die
nächste frage viele studierende leiden
seit monaten massiv unter der sozialen
isolation im lock down und auch sie
persönlich haben ja in interviews für
mehr öffnungen an den hochschulen
plädiert in ihrer konkreten
regierungsarbeit merkt man davon gar
nichts ganz im gegenteil ihre
bundesregierung hat ja am dritten märz
mit den ministerpräsidenten der länder
gemeinsam detailgenaue öffnung schritte
vereinbart für botanische gärten für
opernhäuser für fahr und flugschulen
aber die hochschulen mit ihren drei
millionen studierenden in deutschland
sind ihnen nicht einmal eine erwähnung
wert
auch in der jüngsten gesetzesvorlage
wollen sie nicht mal die möglichkeit
eröffnen dringend notwendige praxis
veranstaltungen wie labor tätigkeiten
beispielsweise praktika in
naturwissenschaften überhaupt noch zu
ermöglichen in vielen landkreisen meine
frage daher an sie waren werden sie
ihren interviews konkrete taten folgen
lassen und welche konkrete öffnungs
perspektive für hochschulen wollen sie
mit ihren länderkollegen vereinbaren ich
bin seit der beginnen seit dem beginn
der pandemie mit meinen wissenschafts
länder wissenschaftsminister kollegen
der länder im direkten austausch weil
wir uns natürlich immer kurzgeschlossen
haben wir haben zum beispiel auf diesem
weg dann eben auch besprochen wie geht
es mit dem bafög wie geht s immer den
finanziellen sorgen und natürlich ist es
jetzt im dritten online semester etwas
anderes als im ersten
ich habe eben gerade gesagt der start
der online lehre in den hochschulen war
relativ gut weil mit
digitalisierung da weil das einfach viel
weiter war und weil sie viel mehr
möglichkeiten hatten es konnten ganz
spontan über die ganze zeit mehr als 75
prozent der lehre in den hochschulen
stattfinden
auf der anderen seite sind aber die
länder auch dazu übergegangen nach dem
ersten komplett locker und bibliotheken
wieder zu öffnen auch wenn es natürlich
eingeschränkte öffnung war auch labor
tätigkeiten sie haben die labor nutzung
entzerrt haben andere möglichkeiten
geschaffen in kleineren gruppen da auch
labor tätigkeiten möglich zu machen und
auch studienseminare gerade jetzt unter
der möglichkeit des testens finden ja
schon wieder statt also es ist nicht so
dass in den hochschulen alles
geschlossen ist aber sie haben natürlich
recht viele viele studierende sitzen
einfach zu hause und gerade die die in
den kleinen studien studentenwohnungen
sitzen sind natürlich schon schwer
betroffen und darauf machen wir auch
aufmerksame werden uns auch da damit
beschäftigen wie können wir zum beispiel
innerhalb von modellprojekten einzelne
möglichkeiten geben gerade auch für
erstsemester die noch nicht mal die
möglichkeit hatten hochschule
kennenzulernen nachfrage kollegen mit
verlaub frau ministerin ich freue mich
ja dass sie inzwischen das problem
zumindest nicht abschreibt abstreiten
dass sie es also offenbar erkannt haben
aber es reicht nämlich auf die abstrakte
möglichkeit von modellprojekten zu
verweisen dass löst ja das problem in
der fläche nicht und bisher sehe ich
zumindest von bundesseite in den
vereinbarungen anders als in den schulen
beispielsweise ja auch
bildungseinrichtungen der länder ist
ihnen nicht gelungen auch nur
ansatzweise gemeinsam eröffnungs
schritte überhaupt so vereinbaren da
einer mal konkrete nachfrage nicht ob
sie in gesprächen sind sondern ob sie es
in der sache richtig finden dass bund
und länder sich bisher überhaupt nicht
auf gemeinsame öffnungs schritte zu
hochschulen einigen sollten oder welchen
konkreten handlungsbedarf sieht deswegen
für die hochschulen geht ja im
wesentlichen das was wir jetzt mit dem
infektionsschutzgesetz festschreiben
dass wir eben bei bestimmten instituten
möglichkeiten schaffen können über
testen gewisse öffnung schritte zu
ermöglichen und daneben wenn die
instanzen zu hoch gehen das dann auf
jeden fall wieder komplett geschlossen
werden muss man muss sich nur bei 1 im
klaren sein
hochschulen sind in der regel keine
kleinen einheiten sondern einheiten wo
mehrere tausend bis hin zu mehr
10.000 schülerinnen und schüler
studentinnen und studenten unterwegs
sind und deswegen ist es dann natürlich
ungleich schwerer konzepte zu erstellen
die dann größere öffnung schritte
ermöglichen ich glaube wir müssen so
ehrlich sein dass wir im moment noch
alle miteinander die zähne
zusammenbeißen müssen ich denke dass wir
einfach auch sehr aufmerksam sein müssen
wo jemand sehr schwer damit klar kommt
wo man jemanden vielleicht auch nicht
mehr erreicht ich denke zum winter sieht
die situation anders aus dass man da
schon auch die perspektive geben kann
das im wintersemester wieder viel mehr
stattfinden kann
stephan albani cdu csu stellt die
nächste frage ja herzlichen dank frau
ministerin und ich komme aus dem bereich
der forschung
sie erwähnten eingelangt in ihren
einführenden worten die firma biotec und
ihr riesiger erfolg
in weniger als einem jahr ein wirkstoff
beziehungsweise einen impfstoff zu
entwickeln
das ist ja ein großer erfolg keine frage
aber der ist ja nicht in diesem einen
jahr entstanden sondern letzten endes
durch eine kontinuierliche förderung an
die 20 jahre vorher schon und insofern
ist meine frage wie reagiert die
bundesregierung wie reagiert ihr haus
auf die nun auftretende mutationen
veränderungen mit entsprechenden
forschungsaktivitäten und auch die frage
inwieweit setzen sie sowohl auf
kurzfristige als aber auch auf
langfristige aktivitäten in diesem
bereich so dass wir sicherstellen können
dass so ein erfolg nicht im bereich des
glückes liegt sondern im bereich der
effektiven planung das ist eine sehr
wahre feststellung dass wir im grunde
ein bisschen glück gehabt haben in
dieser situation dass die entwicklung
der marina technologie durch langjährige
unterstützung aus unserem haus heraus
wir unterstützen allein die firma bayon
tag seit ihrer gründung im jahr 2008
immer mal wieder um eben den fortschritt
an dieser stelle auch systematisch
möglich zu machen das hat in diesem fall
geklappt und gerade auch bei den
mutanten es ist jetzt so dass das
innerhalb der unternehmen noch mal jetzt
darauf geguckt wird wirken die oder
helfen die impfstoffe oder müssen wir
neue entwickeln gerade durch die meere
nato logi ist es relativ einfach
geworden relativ schnell auch für
mutationen wirksame impfstoffe zu
entwickeln und wir haben im
internationalen bereich
ein europäisches netzwerk für
studienzentren und auch den hera
inkubator die ganz gezielt auch die
frage von wirksamkeit der wirkstoffe für
mutanten in den fokus stellen und da die
weiterentwicklung vorantreiben nachfrage
gelegen
die sprache jetzt schon von
internationalität austausch
informationsaustausch aber was sich ja
auch gezeigt hat in der pandemie war die
notwendigkeit konzertierten handelns das
heißt an dieser stelle irgendeiner muss
den hut aufhaben um letzten endes die in
den ländern stattfindenden aktivitäten
auch so zu koordinieren dass ich am ende
zielführend agieren und insofern meine
frage dahingehend wie jenseits der
bilden von plattformen und netzwerken
auch dieses sichergestellt werden kann
was wir brauchen ist das was man in den
usa unter dem stichwort bada gegründet
hat nämlich eine förderagentur die
langfristig bis weiter an die zulassung
fördert wir haben ja bisher immer
grundlagenforschung gefördert und haben
es dann ein stück weit auch dem markt
überlassen ob das eben weiter gefördert
wird und bis in die zulassung kommt und
wir werden uns jetzt und die diskussion
führen wir gerade auf europäischer ebene
und sehr klar dahin fokussieren dass wir
eine eigene förderagentur brauchen die
dieses teil des todes aktiv und aktiv
überschreitet und damit eben auch
reserve antibiotika und solche sachen
fördert weil da gibt es keinen markt für
wenn ich etwas nicht in den markt
bringen darf weil es im grunde der
allgemeinen gesundheit dient um
vorzubereiten für mögliche pandemien
oder zum beispiel auch resistenzen bei
antibiotika dann muss der staat da
eintreten dann ist das eine ganz
wichtige aufgabe die wir zu erfüllen
haben wir dass der markt nicht kann
die kollegin katrin schlaflos cdu csu
möchte nachfrage
vielen dank
ich würde in dem zusammenhang mit der
impfstoffentwicklung ist
im stoff entwicklungsländer hochrisiko
projekte man weiß vorher nie was am ende
dabei rauskommt
insofern wie es die bundesregierung die
sind sie auch mit diesem risiko in der
förderung umgegangen
danke für die nachfrage dass also das
impfstoffentwicklung hochrisiko projekte
sind und dass man eben auch immer
rückschläge verkraften muss deswegen
haben wir im letzten sommer immer wenn
wir gefragt worden sind dann rechnen wir
denn damit oder wann haben wir die
chance haben wir immer darauf
hingewiesen wenn wir im sommer dieses
jahres 20 21 einen impfstoff haben sind
wir richtig gut weil die gefahr einen
rückschlag zu erleben und dann eben noch
mal auch mit einer studie wieder von
neuem beginnen zu müssen weil das eben
relativ hoch ist und deswegen haben wir
jetzt für unser 750 millionen programm
ganz klare eindeutige meilensteine
vorgegeben und immer erst wenn ein
meilenstein erreicht war dann konnte der
nächste schritt der entwicklung gemacht
werden so dass wir niemals denen die wir
gefordert haben das ganze geld auf
einmal gegeben haben sondern schritt für
schritt sie auch eng begleitet haben und
so haben wir eben für den staat das
risiko beherrschbar gehalten
die nächste frage stellt die kollegin dr
petra sitte die linke
danke herr präsident frau minister da
steht man morgens andere s-bahn und
guckt auf die digitale werbetafeln und
was floppt plötzlich auf die
werbekampagne des bmbf zu 50 jahre bafög
denke ich ganz schöner hammer
ich hab noch mal nachgeguckt in dem
bafög-gesetz von 1971 da stand drin
wirklich ausbildungsförderung ist in
einer höhe zu leisten dass der
lebensunterhalt und die individuellen
ausbildungskosten während der
ausbildungszeit angemessen gedeckt sind
also es ging damals um das soziale
versprechen dass gute bildung auch
bessere lebensperspektiven bieten soll
jetzt haben sie bei ihrer amtsübernahme
ungefähr 13 oder 14 prozent der
studierenden überhaupt noch gehabt die
über bafög um die bafög beziehen konnten
sie haben das damals auf der basis des
koalitionsvertrages zu recht heftig
kritisiert jetzt liegen wir und sie
haben von der trendwende gesprochen bei
11,4 prozent und 50 prozent der
studierenden leben unterhalb der
armutsgrenze
was ist aus der trendwende geworden was
erklären sie diesem den studierenden zu
diesem krachenden scheitern
wir haben in dieser legislaturperiode
eine bafög-reform vorgenommen wir haben
insgesamt 1,3 milliarden euro zusätzlich
in das bafög in die sozialleistung bafög
gesteckt und ich glaube wir können
abschließend noch gar nicht beurteilen
ob diese reformen wird aber eins muss
man dazu sagen das bafög ist eine
sozialleistung und vor der krise war es
einfach der fall dass die wirtschaft vom
höchststand zu höchstand ging und eben
auch die beschäftigung sehr sehr gut war
und auch die löhne gestiegen sind und
weil natürlich die der bezug von bafög
subsidiär ist nämlich dann eintritt wenn
eltern nicht leisten können wenn eltern
ihre kinder nicht unterstützen können
bis zum ende der ersten ausbildung muss
man einfach feststellen dass vor der
krise das phänomen schon sehr stark war
dass viele eltern auch eigene
leistungsfähigkeit besaßen um ihre
kinder zu unterstützen
nichtsdestotrotz haben wir gesagt wir
wollen die trend umkehren wir wollen
wieder mehr junge leute erreichen wir
wollen bis in die mitte der gesellschaft
hinein fördern
deswegen haben wir die reform auf den
weg gebracht mit drei stufen die dritte
stufe tritt jetzt im herbst in kraft und
wir werden jetzt im juli die erste
evaluation bekommen für die ersten
beiden jahre
und dann werden wir weiter sehen wenn es
so noch nicht geklappt hat können wir in
der nächsten legislaturperiode ja da
noch mal wieder ansetzen
ja frau minister das erklärte aber immer
nicht noch nicht die armutsrate unter
den studierenden das erklärt nicht die
armutsrate unter wissenschaftlichem
nachwuchs dass sie jetzt noch warten bis
die dritte stufe greift sie haben bei
den beantragungen zu bafög
beziehungsweise zu nothilfen abgewiesen
anträge in höhe von etwa einem drittel
aller antragsteller das ist doch
sozusagen das eingeständnis ihres
eigenen ministeriums das schon vorher
das bafög überhaupt nicht gereicht hat
sie können nur den jungen leuten nicht
erklären denn so eine situation tut uns
leid ihr kriegt jetzt keinen antrag
keine bewilligung weil es euch ja schon
vor der pandemie schlecht ging und das
ist doch damit dann auch das
eingeständnis dafür dass das bafög so
wie sie es beschlossen haben diese
erwartungen überhaupt nicht erfüllen
kann
es gibt mehrere wege sich ein studium zu
finanzieren das eine ist eben dass die
eltern ihre kinder unterstützen was in
der regel auch der fall ist und
ansonsten tritt in der regel des bafög
ein
wichtig ist dass wir glaube ich in der
zukunft auch noch einmal einen blick
darauf werden werfen dass es immer mehr
atypische bildungs verläufe gibt die
eben der klassischen bildung dem die
klassischen bildungsbiographie wie wir
sie kennen zukünftig vielleicht nicht
mehr gerecht wird und dass wir das thema
durchlässigkeit zwischen akademischer
und beruflicher bildung auch mal neu in
den fokus nehmen ich habe eben gesagt
lebenslanges lernen das für uns etwas
was wir auch jetzt in der nächsten
legislaturperiode und auch in dieser
legislaturperiode sehr sehr stark in den
fokus gestellt haben und wenn sie die
überbrückungshilfen ansprechend bei den
überbrückungshilfen haben wir keinen
wert darauf gelegt dass wir denen helfen
die in der pandemie kurzfristig in not
geraten sind damit sie eine neue
möglichkeit finden einen mini job zu
finden und genau da haben wir angesetzt
wir haben mittlerweile 475 an 475.000
anträge bekommen
davon fast 70 prozent positiv beschieden
wir haben geholfen wir haben zum
beispiel auch mit der zins freistellung
des kfw und des kfw studienkredit
geholfen
also ich glaube es gibt viele wege
unterstützung im studium zu finden
man muss sich nur den richtigen für sich
wählen bei den ganz unterschiedlichen
bildungsbiografien kai gehring bündnis
90/die grünen stellt die nächste frage
ja frau ministerin die soziale und
finanzielle lage der studierenden in
unserem land ist verheerend und das ist
ja ein thema die ausbildungs und
studienfinanzierung die zu 100% in ihrer
zuständigkeit liegt das bafög ist auf
einem allzeittief gelandet nur noch elf
prozent erhalten ist und sie haben 2019
und 2020 rund 1,2 milliarden euro nicht
an die studierenden verausgabt sondern
diese mittel sind an den
bundesfinanzminister zurück geflossen
obwohl diese 1,2 milliarden euro fürs
bafög in den haushalt eingeplant wurden
ich möchte von ihnen wissen warum wieso
haben sie diese mittel diese immensen
summen nicht an die studierenden gegeben
zum beispiel über eine bafög korrektur
novelle oder über eine
überbrückungshilfe die auch wirklich
hilft und und überbrückt fehlt ihnen da
am kabinettstisch beim
bundesfinanzminister ist die
unterstützung oder bei den
regierungsfraktionen
das bafög ist eine sozialleistung und
man hat einen rechtsanspruch darauf wir
haben eine bafög reform gemacht die
sowohl die freibeträge sehr stark erhöht
hat als auch die zuweisung sehr stark
erhöht hat und insofern glaube ich nicht
dass man sagen kann dass gerade auch die
bafög-reform die wir gemacht haben nicht
das adressiert hat was sie adressieren
sollen nämlich dass man damit
auskömmlich sein studium finanzieren
kann dass man dann nicht in not geraten
muss und dass man eben auch nicht
umfangreich zusätzlich arbeiten muss
wichtig ist dass wir das sie wissen dass
diese zuweisung als pauschal zuweisung
dem bundeshaushalt kommen da war aber
einen rechtsanspruch darauf hat kann man
sie eben auch nur in diesem sinne
ausgeben und ich habe eben schon mal
darauf hingewiesen
da die wirtschaftslage vor der pandemie
sehr gut war und die löhne gestiegen
sind und eben viele eltern ihre kinder
auch aus eigener kraft unterstützen
können was ich auch für richtig halte
denn am ende wenn wir dieses system
aufgeben wenn wir die subsidiarität
aufgeben dann geben wir genau dass diese
verbindung zum unterhaltsrecht auf das
erstmal älteren eintreten müssen um ihre
kinder zu unterstützen dass der staat
dann nachrangig unterstützt und wenn wir
auf der linken seite des hauses immer
hören dass es darum geht reiche mehr zu
beteiligen dann ist genau das die
beteiligung die sie einfordern und das
sollten wir an der stelle nicht aufgeben
nach also uns geht es darum dass
wirklich die studierenden aus finanzarm
elternhäusern und auch aus der unteren
mittelschicht tatsächlich den genuss des
bafögs
das ist nicht mehr der fall ich möchte
noch mal wiederholen 89 prozent erhalten
kein bafög nach 16 jahren cdu führung im
bmbf
zwölf jahre war die spd dabei und das
war wirklich den trümmern dass es keine
adäquate studienfinanzierung mehr
und jetzt haben sie gerade gesagt die
löhne sind gestiegen da müssen sie mal
die statistik von 2020 sich angucken da
sind die reallöhne gegenüber 2009 10 um
1,1 prozent gesunken und wahrscheinlich
wird es aufgrund der pandemie ja
weitergehen
deshalb ist für uns eine entscheidende
frage wieso haben sie jetzt in ihrem
haushalt für das nächste jahr schon
wieder sinkende bafög zahlen angenommen
wo gleichzeitig die reallöhne jetzt
anfangen zu sinken
und weiter familien in der
finanzschwachen situation sein werden
wie passt das alles zusammen kann es
sein dass die voerder systematik und
logik des bafögs nicht mehr zur
lebensrealität der studierenden passt
also eins habe ich eben gesagt dass wir
diese verzahnung von akademischer und
beruflicher bildung die veränderung von
bildungsbiografien natürlich im fokus
behalten müssen
und dass wir natürlich immer wieder auf
strukturelle veränderungen reagieren
müssen das aber grundsätzlich die
systematik des bafög nicht passt dem
möchte ich ganz ausdrücklich
widersprechen
denn sie haben gerade von individuellen
einkommen gesprochen es wird aber beim
bafög das haushaltseinkommen betrachtet
und natürlich haben dadurch dass
vermehrt eben beide eltern auch in der
arbeit sind und eben einen arbeitsplatz
haben
die haushaltseinkommen natürlich
zugenommen und wir haben die
bafög-reform gemacht so dass bis in die
mitte der gesellschaft hinein bis in ein
einkommen die in der mitte der
gesellschaft verdient werden
unterstützung beantragt werden können
insofern weiß ich das absolut zurück
dass das system überhaupt nicht mehr zu
den lebensrealitäten passt wirkte gesine
lötzsch die linke möchte die nachfolge
stellen
vielen dank herr präsident
frau ministerin sie haben jetzt mehrfach
gesagt bevor der krise vor der krise nun
sind wir aber schon über ein jahr in der
krise und sie werden ja nicht
widersprechen können dass ihre politik
der krise anpassen müssen und diese 500
euro maximal überbrückungshilfen
erreichen ja in den meisten
universitätsstädten ich sage berlin
haben wir künftig überhaupt nicht aus um
das leben zu gestalten und durchs leben
zu kommen
nebenjobs sind weggefallen 800.000
nebenjobs wie wollen sie sichern dass
die studierenden in der krise gut durch
die krise kommen und sich von den
konzepten von vor der krise müssen sich
doch jetzt wohl verabschieden oder
wollen sie mir da widersprechen wir
haben in der krise sehr schnell
maßnahmen getroffen die erste maßnahme
war die dass wir aktualisierungs anträge
für das bafög möglich gemacht haben wenn
plötzlich eben das einkommen der eltern
sich verändert hat oder eben auch wenn
man selbst sein eigenes einkommen
verändert hat wir haben als zweites die
überbrückungshilfen möglich gemacht und
wir haben ganz gezielt den betrag von
500 euro gewählt weil ein nebenjob kann
in der regel im monat 450 euro betragen
ansonsten ist er nämlich ist das etwas
was sozialversicherungspflichtig ist und
dann hat er nämlich über über die hilfen
des sgb andere möglichkeiten sich zu
sich also ersatz zu besorgen
wir haben sehr klar wert darauf gelegt
dass denen denen der mini jobs
weggefallen ist eine möglichkeit zur
verfügung steht sich kurzfristig
anderweitig zu finanzen
man sieht ja wir haben das jetzt über
die zeit der pandemie ausgeweitet wir
werden das noch weiter finanzieren bis
zum september diesen jahres also noch
über das ganze sommersemester wir haben
den kfw studienkredit nochmals ins
freigestellt damit man auch über den weg
die möglichkeit hat sich noch eine
zusätzliche finanzierung zu organisieren
all das ist relativ schnell beschieden
worden die studierenden werke haben sich
wirklich angehalten kurzfristig alle
möglichen nöte wirklich zu überbrücken
also insofern kann man vielleicht an der
stelle auf den studierenden werken
einmal danke sagen herr kollege jährigen
da die kollegin zu ihrer frage der
nachfolge stellt hat können sie schlecht
zu sich selber noch eine nachfrage
stellen
und deswegen hat jetzt die nächste frage
der kollege doch regierungen afd
ja sehr geehrte frau ministerin vor
kurzem hat sich ein netzwerk
wissenschaftsfreiheit gegründet dem über
400 renommierte professoren angehören
wie ulrike ackermann jörg barofsky
wolfgang streeck und viele andere in
einer pressemitteilung dieses netzwerks
von anfang februar ist von einer
zunehmenden verengung der
fragestellungen themen und argumenten in
der akademischen forschung die rede
die zu einem klima an den universitäten
geführt habe in dem abweichende
positionen und meinungen an den rand
gedrängt und moralisch sanktioniert
werden zitat ende
die fdp fraktion weist schon lange
darauf hin dass politiker correctness
und cancel culture eine freie debatte an
deutschen universitäten so gut wie
verunmöglicht haben man denke nur an
luca borowski münkler und andere deren
vorlesungen gestört und niedergebrüllt
wurden auf unsere kleine anfrage zur
wissenschaftsfreiheit hat die
bundesregierung im dezember 2009 10 noch
geantwortet dass keine bedrohung der
wissenschaftsfreiheit vorliege und sie
daher auch keine forschungsprojekte
hierzu in auftrag gegeben haben erkennen
sie mittlerweile an dass hier ein
massives problem vorliegt und wenn ja
was gedenken sie von bundesseite aus zur
wahrung bzw auch wiederherstellung der
wissenschaftsfreiheit zu unternehmen
also ich möchte einmal für die
bundesrepublik deutschland feststellen
dass wir sehr sehr großen wert auf
wissenschaftsfreiheit legen weil wir den
wert der wissenschaftsfreiheit
ja sehr hoch halten und wir haben im
rahmen unserer eu ratspräsidentschaft
die bonner erklärung auf den weg
gebracht weil wir natürlich wissen dass
wissenschaftsfreiheit eben auch ein
motor ist und wir in ganz europa wert
darauf legen wir sind mittlerweile so
erfolgreich gewesen dass alle die die
wissenschaft die die bonner erklärung
unterschreiben wollten sie am ende auch
unterschrieben haben und wir damit noch
einmal den fokus auf
wissenschaftsfreiheit gelenkt haben und
gerade in unseren hochschulen legen wir
großen wert auf die offene diskussion
und ich kann das was sie sagen nicht in
der breite feststellen dass mag immer
wieder einmal einen einzelnen vorfall
geben dem wird aber nachgegangen und
dann wird eben auch dafür gesorgt dass
die wissenschaftsfreiheit ihre freiheit
behält nach weil wir ja bitte
ja es ist ja erfreulich dass sie
zumindest ansatzweise hier etwas zu tun
gedenken wenngleich das auch so unserer
sicht noch nicht ausreicht sind sie denn
bereit auch zu evaluieren inwieweit
diese so genannten agenda wissenschaften
also gender studies postkolonialer
staates kritiker leitner studies die in
von ihrem selbstverständnis her das
ideal der wissenschaftlichen
objektivität teils auch ganz aggressiv
ablehnen
sind sie bereit zu evaluieren inwieweit
diese eben ganz massiv zu diesem klima
beitragen von wem die wissenschaftler
hier sprechen und zu einer einschränkung
der wissenschaftsfreiheit führen und
sind sie dann auch bereits konsequenzen
zu ziehen und hier eben keine sonder
förderungsprogramme stichwort über 200
professoren in deutschland mehr
aufzulegen
also eines ist klar dass zb in der
medizin um mal dass die genderforschung
aufrecht zu halten in der medizin ist
das ein ganz wesentlicher aspekt weil
natürlich zum beispiel bei medikamenten
die wirkung bei frauen häufig ganz
anders ist als bei männern und da
vielleicht mal dazu einen anderen fokus
und das zweite ist sehr sehr klar
wissenschaftsfreiheit ist für uns ein
motor in der wissenschaft und deswegen
halten wir aus der wissenschaft heraus
und wir sind im engen austausch mit all
unseren organisationen in der
wissenschaft halten wir diese
wissenschaftsfreiheit hoch und wir
können das was sie behaupten nicht
erkennen und insofern ist da
auch noch keine notwendigkeit lüge bahr
spd stellt die nächste frage vielen dank
frau ministerin ich möchte einen bereich
anstrengende jetzt noch zu kurz gekommen
ist nämlich die azubis der azubi
schutzschirm der substanzverlust auf dem
ausbildungsmarkt gesetzt schon spürbar
und er ist auch nicht ohne weiteres auf
aufholbar wir haben hier einige gute
schritte gemacht in der koalition und
auch zielgenauer ausgestaltet aber
dennoch glaube ich dass es noch weitere
nächste schritte braucht da wäre die
frage an sie was tun sie oder welche
ansätze sehen sie dahingehend dass das
duale system zu sichern ist dass es
gesichert ist und jeden jugendlichen
einen ausbildungsplatz garantiert wird
vielen dank für die frage ich glaube
beispiel am anfang damit beginnen einmal
zu sagen dass die berufliche ausbildung
gerade in fragen des fachkräftemangels
für uns ein ganz ganz hohen stellenwert
hat weil wir sehen in ganz vielen
bereichen dass wir gerade im bereich der
beruflichen ausbildung im moment eine
hohe nachfrage haben und wenn das
vielleicht auch in der pandemie häufig
nicht so deutlich wird aber wir werden
sehen dass sobald die pandemie abebbt
das thema fachkräftemangel wieder dass
etwas bei uns ganz oben auf der agenda
steht wir haben auch den
ausbildungsmarkt ganz genau im blick
aber es gibt im moment noch keine
belastbaren zahlen dazu werden im
letzten herbst gesehen dass es einen
großen nachholen und wir gehen davon aus
dass es auch in diesem jahr ein
nachholeffekt geben wird aber es gibt
sehr sehr viele unbekannte insgesamt
kann man sagen dass der gesamtmarkt auch
2020 geschrumpft ist so dass es eben
ungefähr elf prozent weniger verträge
gegeben hat aber der markt es eben in
der gesamtheit geschrumpft auf der
angebots und der nachfrageseite so dass
wir nach wie vor in der glücklichen
situation sind dass wir einem
ausbildungswilligen auch einen
ausbildungsplatz anbieten können und das
ist genau der punkt wir müssen uns mit
dem matching beschäftigen das matching
war auch schon vor der pandemie die
große frage wie bekommen wir die außen
gekommen wir sowohl branchenspezifisch
als auch regionen spezifisch angebot und
nachfrage zusammen
und wir haben jetzt in der pandemie auch
digitale matching plattform oder
matching möglichkeiten unterstützt und
ich glaube dass wir da auch dass sein
womit wir uns nach der pandemie als
erstes wieder noch mal auseinandersetzen
müssen wie kann man das noch mal
verkümmern
wichtig ist mir aber einfach auch noch
mal zu sagen dass die berufliche
ausbildung durch unsere durch unsere
reformen die wir gemacht haben jetzt
eine ganz andere möglichkeit hat eben
auch den aufstieg sichtbar zu machen und
damit auch die karriereperspektiven
sichtbar zu machen nachfrage ministerin
ich bin davon überzeugt dass ein junger
mensch der einen guten ausbildungsplatz
dann auch ergattern will und auch eine
antwort natürlich darauf hat aber von
früh an von klein an auch gefördert sein
muss nämlich an der grundschule und da
haben wir ein noch ungelöstes vorhaben
in der koalition im koalitionsvertrag
stehen nämlich die umsetzung der
einführung des rechtsanspruchs auf
ganztagsbetreuung im grundschulbereich
und da ist meine frage wie plant die
bundesregierung die umsetzung des
projekts voranzutreiben zumal da
natürlich die legislaturperiode dahin ja
wir haben ja vor weihnachten habe ich
mit der kollegin franziska gefallen
zusammen den ersten beschleunigungs kopf
auf den weg gebracht so dass die länder
quasi schon anfangen können den ganztags
ausbau mit mit kleineren kleineren
investitionen zu beginnen
wir sind jetzt dabei weil wir ganz
großen wert darauf legen dass es
wirklich einen rechtsanspruch gibt es
soll klar sein dass eltern in diesem
land bis zum zehnten lebensjahr bis zum
ende der grundschule ihre kinder auf
jeden fall betreut bekommen und dass sie
eben auch ein hochwertiges
bildungsangebot bekommen wir sind mit
den ländern im austauschen beginn davon
aus dass wir noch erfolgreich sein
werden das auch noch umzusetzen
weil die erste stelle kollege dr martin
neumann fdp die nächste kundin
vielen dank herr präsident noch mal eine
nachfrage zum thema berufsförderung mir
ist also über arbeitsagentur
signalisiert von dass da zu wenig oder
ich sag mal nichts stattfindet gerade
auch sicherlich bedingt durch die
bedingungen jetzt in der korona pandemie
also die verbindung zu den schulen
zwischen den arbeitsagenturen was
gedenken sie zu tun um genau wo sich an
mit diesem thema zu beschäftigen weil
das glaube ich auch aufgrund der zeit
die jetzt verstrichen ist glaube ich ein
riesen nachholebedarf gibt man das
aufholen kann
also wie gesagt es hat im letzten sommer
einen großen nachholeffekt gegeben und
wir haben natürlich den fokus darauf was
können wir jetzt tun wir wollen den
sommer der berufsbildung zusammen mit
den anbietern machen also mit den
kammern um nochmal den fokus sehr stark
dahin zu lenken dass ein nur eine
wirklich hochwertige berufliche
ausbildung wie wir sie hier in
deutschland anbieten eine echte
alternative zum studium ist weil wir
einfach um den wert der ausbildung
wissen und wie gesagt das matching habe
ich angesprochen aber wir machen jetzt
erstmal den sommer der berufsbildung um
den fokus auch noch mal dorthin zu
lenken
wir haben ja auch kampagnen zur
berufsbildung und aldi werden wir weiter
führen und wir werden auch sehr klaren
noch mal das thema berufsorientierung
sobald die schulen wieder losgehen in
den fokus kai gehring schild in excel
nachfrage wohl du nicht doch ich wollte
noch mal nachfragen weil wir hier im
hohen haus mehr über die studierenden
wissen als über die auszubildenden und
das widerspricht ja auch der
gleichwertigkeit beruflicher und
akademischer bildung die wir miteinander
wollen warum verschließen sie sich
nachdem es ja die sozialerhebung für
studierende gibt und auch das
studierendensurvey warum verschließen
sie sich weiter dem vorschlag ein
auszubildenden erhebung zu machen
eine auszubildenden sowie weil wir ganz
wichtig ja auch in ihrer zuständigkeit
der bildungsforschung hier dringend mehr
erkenntnisse brauchen wir haben da wir
ja zu den auszubildenden ein
vertragliches verhältnis haben was
wesentlich enger und konkreter ist als
das was wir im studierenden bereich
haben haben wir sehr viele informationen
über die auszubildenden und wissen auch
eine menge über die auszubildenden wir
werden aber in den nächsten jahren wir
mussten das verschieben aufgrund der
prohner pandemie noch einmal eine große
und eine große umfrage machen was bewegt
die jungen leute wo möchten sie hin
warum präferieren viele doch das studium
und nicht die ausbildung und ich kann
das an dieser stelle immer nur
wiederholen diese hochwertige berufliche
ausbildung die wir hier in deutschland
anbieten ist ein pfund was kaum ein land
in der welt hat worum uns die welt
beneidet und das kann ich nur immer
wieder betonen auch in dem bereich zu
gucken gerade im bereich der
technologisch innovativen betriebe hat
sich in den letzten jahren viel getan da
ist übrigens der ausbildungsmarkt auch
sehr offen und da kann ich jungen leute
nur empfehlen sich das auch genau
anzuschauen
norbert müller stellt die dritte und
letzte nachfrage zu diesem frage ja
vielen dank herr präsident vor
carlitscheck ich möchte gerne bei
regelbaren schließen weil ich die frage
für überaus bedeutsam halt im
koalitionsvertrag haben die regierenden
parteien an zwei punkten wortwörtlich
festgehalten also die pacers der satz
zweimal gleich eingefügt worden daran
sieht man wie wichtig da war
wir werden einen rechtsanspruch auf
ganztagsbetreuung grundschulalter
schaffen und ich bin davon ausgegangen
der bar mit auf diese wahlperiode
gemünzte nicht auf eine perspektivisch
folgende da diese wahlperiode abläuft
und wie immer noch keinen gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt bekommen haben und sie mit
federführend sind ist meine erste frage
wann wird der gesetzentwurf in den
deutschen bundestag eingebracht werden
zum rechtsanspruch und zweitens im
koalitionsvertrag hat man ja ein
hintertürchen eingebaut da steht die
schöne formulierung drin dass der
rechtsanspruch nur dann kommen wird wenn
ausreichend fachkräfte zur verfügung
sind jetzt wissen wir die sind ja gar
nicht zur verfügung was wird die
bundesregierung tun nachdem sie die
fachkräfte offensive wieder abgewürgt
haben im kabinett was wären sie dafür
tun dass ausreichend fachkräfte da sind
wenn der rechtsanspruch auf den ganzen
dann irgendwann vielleicht einmal kommt
20-25 geben und ja ich habe gerade
gesagt wir sind mit den ländern in einem
guten gespräch dass wir davon ausgehen
können dass das gesetz in dieser
legislaturperiode noch verabschiedet
werden kann
aber der rechtsanspruch selbst kommt ab
20 25 und insofern gibt es dann auch
noch genügend zeit personal anzuwerben
und eben auch personal auszubilden um
eben dann eben auch qualitativ gute
angebote machen zu können
britta dassler fdp stellt die nächste
frage wer hätte frau ministerin
carlitscheck meine frage geht in
richtung alphabetisierung und alpha
dekade und ich würde gerne von ihnen
wissen haben sie und damit ihr
ministerium und damit auch die ganze
bundesregierung kenntnis davon dass
träger der alphabetisierung
hilfesuchenden menschen aufgrund der
groner bedingten schließungen der
bildungsinstitutionen der
basiskompetenzen ich denke da an
volkshochschulen ich denke an
mehrgenerationenhäuser derzeit nicht
weitervermitteln können weil es so haben
wir es gehört keine adäquaten digitale
angebote gibt und dann ist die frage
welche maßnahmen wurden im rahmen der
alpha die gerade 216 bis am 22
seit ausbruch der pandemie ergriffen um
hier ganz schnell für diese menschen
ersatzangebote zu schaffen damit wir
gerade die gierigen liberalisierten
menschen in der pandemie nicht alleine
lassen denn aus der groner krise darf
keine bildungskrise werden und diese
menschen sind sowieso schon
benachteiligt die korona pandemie hat
alle bildungsinstitutionen im ersten
moment kalt erwischt so dass sie sich
erst mal eben auch aufstellen mussten um
angebote zu schaffen aber gerade zum
beispiel die volkshochschulen haben sehr
niedrigschwellige digitale angebote
gerade auch für die alphabetisierung
schon im vorfeld gehabt oft liegt es
auch eben auf der nachfrageseite dass
die nicht den zugang dazu finden und das
ist natürlich ein problem was sich in
der pandemie durch die mangel
oder durch die verringerte möglichkeit
überhaupt menschen zu erreichen schon
auch noch verschärft hat aber dass die
angebote da sind und dass man eben sie
niedrigschwellig erreichen kann ich habe
mit der bildung mit der bundeskanzlerin
zusammen die die gibt die initiative
digitale bildung auf den weg gebracht wo
wir ja auch noch mal eine sehr
niedrigschwellige app für die digitale
bildung auf den weg gebracht haben
diesen weg werden wir fortsetzen und
immer wieder auch angebote anpassen auch
so anpassen dass sie für jeden
zugänglich sind nachfrage vorgelegen
finde ich gut wichtig und richtig aber
ist es genug frau ministerin wir reden
immer im bildungsausschuss davon
digitalisierung ist es wichtigste im
moment überhaupt auf dem bildungssektor
damit wir nach vorne kommen
in welchem umfang wurden denn jetzt von
ihrem ministerium maßnahmen ergriffen
und von welchem monetären faktor reden
wir der da zur verfügung stellt wurde
also wir haben mit der app digital zur
digitalen bildung stadland datenfluss im
grunde ein projekt umgesetzt als auch im
koalitionsvertrag stand was wir geplant
hatten wo wir eben auch die mittel
geplant hatten wir haben in dem bereich
auch mit dem nationalen digitalen
bildungsraum jetzt schaffen wir eine
digitale infrastruktur um das ganz
systematisch auch sichtbar zu machen und
zugänglich zu machen für jeden ist das
genug ich glaube wir haben mit der
alphabetisierungskampagne und mit den
unterschiedlichen instrumenten es im
ersten schritt geschafft von 7,5
millionen funktionalen analphabeten in
deutschland auf 6,2 zu kommen und das
ist ein langer und kein ganz einfacher
weg immer wieder die guten zugänge zu
schaffen
diesen weg werden wir weiter gehen und
wir werden immer wieder und auch n
diesem ganzen prozess begleiten die
passenden zugänge zu finden es ist nicht
immer nur eine frage von geld es ist
häufig auch eine frage von
erreichbarkeit und deswegen ist die
frage was entwickeln wir da das eine
aber wie kriegen wir die menschen dann
eben auch dahin diese angebote zu nutzen
und auch niedrigschwellig eben ganz klar
zu machen wir freuen uns über jeden der
auch mit fortgeschrittenem alter einfach
nochmal diese chance nutzt und sich
dadurch ein stück freiheit im leben
verschafft mir gibt wohl die legen
möchte dazu einen nach
ja ich würde gern das thema grundbildung
alphabetisierung an aufgreifen meiner
kollegin wir brauchen das für motivierte
beschäftigte
das hat mit arbeitsbedingungen das hat
mit einkommens strukturen zu tun
ich halte das für eine ganz
problematische baustelle gerade in
diesem bereich deshalb meine frage
welche instrumentarien würden sie nutzen
auch was ist dass der blick auf
kabinettskollegen betrifft um an dieser
stelle bessere arbeitsbedingungen
bessere honorar ankunfts möglichkeiten
für diese kolleginnen und kollegen in
der weiterbildung zu schaffen
ich glaube wir haben in den letzten
jahren viel dafür getan um die
arbeitsbedingungen schritt für schritt
in allen bereichen zu verbessern man
kann ja den bildungsmarkt nicht
ausnehmen wir haben auch gerade im
hochschulbereich überall wo es um
befristete arbeitsverhältnisse ging sehr
dafür gesorgt dass da wo es möglich ist
eben auch um die befristung abgeschafft
werden kann oder zumindest
runtergefahren werden kann um eben auch
stabilität zu geben und das gilt
natürlich auch für diese bereiche katrin
staffler cdu csu stellt die nächste
frage ja vielen dank wir haben jetzt
viel über die auswirkungen der familie
gesprochen über studierende über die
schulen auch über die berufliche bildung
ich würde gerne noch einmal einen
anderen punkt in den fokus nehmen auf
denen die pandemie doch auch durchaus
auch deutliche auswirkungen hat und zwar
das deutsche wissenschaftssystem das ja
auch durchaus durch die auswirkungen
unter druck gerät deswegen meine frage
was tut denn die bundesregierung was tun
sie dafür dass das deutsche
wissenschaftssystem dass wir nach der
krise mehr denn je brauchen werden um
auch gut aus der krise zu kommen um
dieses system zu unterstützen
dankeschön dankeschön wir haben die drei
wissenschafts praktisch und vor der
pandemie verabschiedet wir wollen
nämlich ganz klar in einer
transformation zeit wo wir wissen
dass wir eben großen wert auf
unterstützung aus wissenschafts und auch
hochschuleinrichtungen brauchen um
diesen transformationsprozess zu
gestalten viele innovationen in diesen
tagen kommen aus dem hochschul und
wissenschaftssystem
und deswegen haben wir vor der krise mit
den drei wissenschafts packten
rechtzeitig finanzielle sicherheit
gegeben für hochschulen und
außeruniversitäre
forschungseinrichtungen wir haben mit
dem zukunftsvertrag studium und lehre
jährlich vier milliarden sicher zur
verfügung gestellt und damit schaffen
wir mehr dauer stellen für die
wissenschaftler bessere
arbeitsbedingungen für die
wissenschaftler
wir haben dann ein zweiter mit dem
zweiten akt stiftung innovation in der
hochschullehre auch noch mal die
erneuerung die innowi hrung des
hochschulsystems selbst in angriff
genommen und das ist übrigens weltweit
einmalig das gibt es in keinem anderen
land der welt und dass wir in den
nächsten zehn jahren auch über die
exzellenz strategie dauerhaft
universitäre spitzenforschung stärken
das sind genau die beiträge und genau
die veränderungen die wir jetzt in den
letzten jahren vorgenommen haben um für
diesen transformationsprozess der gerade
wahnsinnig fahrt aufnimmt gut
aufgestellt zu sein und damit eben auch
in der lage zu sein die großen
herausforderungen die großen
veränderungen zuständen nachfrage dank
sie haben angesprochen denen die
nachfolge des qualitätspakt lehre also
die stiftung wir merken ja gerade jetzt
gerade in der pandemie dass das thema
digitalisierung der lehre eine
riesengroße rolle spielt wo wir auch
schnell noch mehr an fahrt aufnehmen
müssen deswegen die frage ist das ein
thema das in dieser stiftung auch
entsprechend abgebildet wird wir haben
ja schon in dem alten qualitätspakt
lehre das thema digitalisierung der
hochschulen in den fokus gestellt
das war genau der grund warum in den
hochschulen viel besser durchgestartet
werden konnte als die schulen oder als
die hochschulen geschlossen worden sind
das wird jetzt auch noch weiter gehen
denn am ende geht es um online
unterstützte lehre also präsenz und
online zusammen zu denken um
ohne richtige lern tools zu entwickeln
um eben auch den besseren zugang die
besseren unterschiede in der art des
lernens sowohl im hochschul als auch im
schulbereich besser angehen zu können
das ist übrigens genau der punkt der zur
chancengerechtigkeit für jeden und so
individuellen bildungswegen führt und
das ist ein fortschritt den wir glaube
ich in diesen tagen sehr gut brauchen
können sagte gesine lötzsch stille in
geschickte lag die frage vielen dank
herr präsident ho ministerin sie haben
ihren vortrag begonnen mit dem thema
impfstoffe und darauf möchte ich
zurückkommen
es ist ja sind ja viele millionen euro
auch in der krise in diese
impfstoffentwicklung hineingesteckt
worden warum hat die bundesregierung
nicht von anfang an vertraglich
gesichert dass der patentschutz
eingeschränkt beziehungsweise besser
noch aufgehoben wird finde das ist das
gebot der stunde
das wichtigste was wir leisten muss ist
dass wir in sehr kurzer zeit motivierte
unternehmen finden die im grunde in der
lage sind auch kurzfristig an dieser
impfstoff entwicklung zum erfolg zu
kommen was wir machen mit unserer
förderung ist ein ist gehört ins
zuwendung recht und dem sind ganz klar
auch grenzen gesetzt was wir damit tun
können wir können nämlich zum beispiel
eben uns auch keine kauf kapazitäten an
der stelle sichern auch das ist immer
schon mal wieder diskutiert werden wir
geben durch die zuwendung und durch eine
enge begleitung die möglichkeit viel
schneller zum ziel zu kommen das hat man
gesehen dass das erfolgreich war die
beschaffung und letztendlich auch alle
weiteren regularien wie man dann von ihm
belegen den anderen häusern aber nicht
bei uns nachfrage
[Applaus]
präsident erlaubt mir erstmal die
bemerken dass ich davon ausgehe und
hoffe dass es menschen gibt bei denen
die motivation nicht alleine am gelde
hängt aber das nebenbei sie haben vorhin
im zusammenhang mit den impfstoffen auch
die impfung von lehrerinnen und lehrern
erwähnt warum haben sie sich nicht dafür
eingesetzt dass in diese oft
priorisierung auch berufsschullehrerin
und lehrer aufgenommen werden wir haben
bei der hochstufung der priorisierung
für lehrkräfte und erzieher ganz klar
wert darauf gelegt dass wir die pri
hochstufen bei denen das abstandhalten
nicht so einfach ist weil sie einfach
mit kleineren mit spontanen kindern
unterwegs sind in der kita da wissen wir
alle genau wie spontan da das geschehen
ist und auch in der grundschule ist das
im wesentlichen noch der fall und
deswegen haben wir die hochstufung und
die priorisierung von lehrerinnen und
lehrern und eben auch erzieherinnen und
erziehern ganz klar dahin gelegt wo wir
sicher sind dass es schwieriger ist
abstand zu halten
bei erwachsenen gehe ich davon aus dass
man gute konzepte finden kann um
sicherheit und abstand zu gewährleisten
und dass ich dann auch alle daran halten
können und ich möchte noch mal eins das
zudem sagen was sie vorher gesagt haben
motivation und geld es ging ja gar nicht
darum dass die motivation nur am geld
hängt aber wenn ich nicht in der lage
bin
studien in einer größenordnung von
40.000 mehr zu gewährleisten weil das
nämlich etwas kostet da hilft mir die
beste motivation nichts an der stelle
brauche ich auch geld deswegen hat das
eine sehr wohl etwas mit dem anderen zu
tun aber die motivation hängt nicht
allein am geld
rainer kraft afd hat eine nachfrage dazu
ja vielen dank frau minister in ihrem
eingang statement hatten sie auch
erwähnt dass sie darauf hin arbeiten
möchten eine wiederansiedlung für
pharmazeutische produktion in
deutschland zu gewährleisten
grundvoraussetzung dafür ist natürlich
der die existenz einer chemischen
industrie die diese grundstoffe für die
pharmazeutische industrie zurückstellt
ich muss an dieser stelle aber natürlich
feststellen dass es die das ziel der
regierung derzeit ist die chemische
industrie in deutschland durch eine
klimapolitik in ihrer arbeit in ihrer
wirtschaftlichkeit zu behindern und das
hier natürlich auch mit ihren absichten
sich vom nicht europäischen markt durch
den durch kabel border tax das besteuern
von stoffen von chemischen produkten die
nicht unter theo 20 produktion
hergestellt worden sind dass sie dann
auch den zugang von zu diesen stoffen
aus dem ausländischen markt begrenzen
das heißt das steht ja wohl ihrer
anliegen eine pharmazeutische chemische
produktion in deutschland wieder
aufzubauen diametral entgegen
das sehe ich überhaupt nicht so wir sind
mit der chemischen industrie im gespräch
weil wir natürlich wissen um die
herausforderungen denen sie
gegenüberstehen
auf der anderen seite stelle ich gerade
in der chemischen industrie und in dem
innovationssystem was wir mittlerweile
darum haben sehr wohl fest statt
bereitschaft besteht sich unter dem
prinzip energie muss bezahlbar und
effizient bleiben sehr wohl alle auf den
weg machen wollen um am ende diesen
klimawandel auch bewältigen zu können
und da bin ich sehr sehr froh weil das
ist nicht immer so gewesen aber wir
haben in den letzten jahren an
netzwerken gearbeitet um zum beispiel
auch thema wasserstoff und all diese
fragen die natürlich auch für die
chemische industrie interessant sind so
in die praxis hinterher umsetzen zu
können wir haben sehr viele
forschungsprojekte in dem bereich dazu
einfach um es auch machbar zu machen
natürlich ist das eine aufgabe und
natürlich geht das nicht von heute auf
morgen aber ich bin froh dass heute die
bereitschaft besteht sich gemeinsam auf
den weg zu machen mit der industrie
das ist ja auch eine sicht auf
unternehmen die nächste frage stellt die
kollegin christmann dank es war jetzt
heute schon häufiger vom verheerenden
scheitern die rede das bringt mich zu
meinem thema der forschungs fertigung
batteriezelle über die wir uns ja in
diesem haus schon häufiger ausgetauscht
haben
jetzt war nicht ganz überraschend zu
lesen dass sich die umbauten und gebäude
erstellen stadt bis 2022 bis 2026
hinziehen werden also vier jahre
verspätung und wir erinnern uns ja über
ausführliche diskussion über den
vergabeprozess wo gerade ihr haus ja das
kriterium der schon bestehenden gebäude
um schnell loslegen zu können
nach hinten gedrängt hatte also sie mit
dazu beigetragen haben dass es ein
standort geworden ist der eben noch
keine gebäude hat wir sehen jetzt es
führt zu erheblichen verzögerungen
das in einer welt in der wrestler in der
andere natürlich längst weiter arbeiten
deswegen möchte ich sie fragen war das
nicht ein scheitern mit ansage und hat
ihr haus nicht da sehr viel dazu
beigetragen dass wir jetzt erst sehr
verspätet zur batteriezellen forschung
beitragen werden können an diesem
standort liebe frau christ fallen das
weise ich entschieden zurück weil wir
schon heute in der batterieforschung
einen wirklich substanziellen beitrag
leisten wir bauen die batterieforschung
seit mitte der oder seit dem ersten
jahrzehnt der 2000er jahre wieder auf
wir haben eine sehr leistungsfähige
batterie forschung in deutschland und
wir stellen noch fest dass durch die
diskussionen und durch unsere
initiativen mittlerweile auch die
industrielle seite sehr bereit ist eine
eigene patent und batterieproduktion
wieder aufzubauen und ich denke schon
dass das im wesentlichen darauf
zurückzuführen ist dass wir über unsere
initiativen über unsere langfristigen
maßnahmen wesentlich zu dieser
aufbruchstimmung beigetragen haben ich
kann mich noch an erste diskussion
erinnern da wollte keiner an das
batterie thema auf der industrieseite so
richtig ran insofern ist auch eine menge
passiert
abseits auch der batterieforschung
fertigung die batterieforschung
fertigung hat im laufe der zeit wo jetzt
diese kleinteilige konzeptionierung
stattgefunden hat ist sie erweitert
worden und deswegen haben wir jetzt das
ganze projekt in zwei teile geteilt der
erste abschnitt wird pünktlich zu 20 22
in den betrieb gehen und der zweite teil
wird bis 2025 fertig gestellt was
ursprünglich bis 2026 fertiggestellt
werden sollte wir sind also sogar ein
jahr früher
wir haben jetzt nur zwei teile daraus
gemacht weil es größer wird beim
mittlerweile auch das land
nordrhein-westfalen 180 millionen euro
da rein steckt vielen dank
mir scheint sie haben da eine andere
wahrnehmung als wir der presse entnehmen
können wo ja vertreter auch von
unternehmen sagen dass eigentlich kein
unternehmen mehr der forschungs
fertigung noch positiv gegenüber stünde
da sind forderungen im raum die
reißleine zu ziehen und das geld auch an
anderer stelle vielleicht sinnvoller
auszugeben
das ist zu lesen in verschiedenen
pressestimmen das hieß auch es sei eine
zäsur dass das jetzt so nach hinten
geschoben ist deswegen möchte ich sie
noch mal fragen
sie nehmen das jetzt zur kenntnis dass
sich dieser prozess länger hinzieht und
haben aber nicht vor
das geld irgendwie anders in der
zwischenzeit zu investieren und wird das
denn überhaupt dann wie geplant
abschließen können also wie gesagt wir
liegen mit den planungen im zeitplan
wir begleiten aus unserem haus heraus
aber eben auch aus dem land nordrhein
westfalen die ja im ohne die gebäude die
die gebäude erstellung begleiten müssen
sehr eng dieses projekt und das was in
der zeitung kolportiert wird kann ich
also so nicht feststellen ich glaube das
liegt ein missverständnis vor
das mal eben diese zweiteilung des
projektes nicht so sieht wie wir sie
denn planen vielleicht müssen wir noch
ein bisschen aufklärung leisten soweit
ich fragen von bundesbildungsministerin
an jack ali treki den abgeordneten des
bundestags rede und antwort stand ja und
sie haben es gehört die soziale und
finanzielle lage der studierenden in der
korona pandemie hat hier eine große
rolle bei den fragen gestellt gespielt
aber auch beispielsweise die geplante
nachhilfe milliarde für schüler die bund
und länder gerade vereinbaren da geht es
ja um die lern rückstände auf grund der
pandemie die aufgeholt werden sollen
also
soweit hier wie gesagt die befragung ich
darf sie noch darauf hinweisen dass wir
um 16.30 und hier live wieder aus dem
bundestag melden werden denn das ist ja
der erste sitzungstag in dieser plenar-
und parlamentswoche und dann wird es um
die teilhabe und die rolle von frauen an
friedensprozessen gehen und um die
umsetzung einer entsprechenden un
resolution also 16.30 wieder hier live
aus dem bundestag aber jetzt geht es
weiter mit weiteren aktuellen themen in
unserem studio in bonn mit bernd rasen
die direkt am projekt beteiligt sind
unter vier augen nennen aber da brauchen
sie keine aufklärungsarbeit leisten
sondern das sind akteure die direkt
involviert sind
bitte nehmen sie dazu stellung schon
einmal ist es doch so dass man an dieser
stelle noch aufklärung leisten müssen
und das ist immer so gewesen dass diese
dass der erste teil der kleinere teil
ist weil natürlich eben auch am ende die
gebäude erstellung der größere teil ist
der daneben für den zweiten für die
zweite für die zweite phase geplant